well today it is you darvish the former
cub he was a cub for three seasons and
this year he's been the padres most
consistent starter jack peterson digs in
one and two to peterson and that's
strike three darvish starts the day off
with a strikeout he's got that pitch
working for you that's the split finger
down and away look at the movement on
that pitch one out nobody on three and
two to ian hat
swing and a miss and darver starts his
day with back-to-back strikeouts two
down after going three-and-oh he battles
back two quick outs via the strikeout
he's got the feel for that breaking ball
there it is and the cubs pitcher jake
the snake arietta on the hill tommy pham
who
is a very patient hitter the strength
two pitch on the way to fam
strike three called
sinking fastball hit the knees on the
outside edge bottom corner right there
there's that two seamer sinker that he
uses run that back out and sometimes you
just gotta tip your cap the pitcher
makes a great pitch it's
now ground ball to third scooped up by
wisdom he'll toss across and that's in
plenty of time we'll head to the second
without a score jarvis going out for his
second inning of work as anthony rizzo
leads off against you darvish the pitch
from darvis swung on a missed strike
three fastball at 96 down in the zone
and now three k's early on for darvish
one down in the top of the second rafael
ortega left-handed batter another one in
two doors
and a swing and a miss make it four
strikeouts scaratini's got to throw him
out and he does back-to-back case for
darvish here in the second inning two
down two down here in the second inning
for jason hayward
2-2 is popped up first base way carrying
hospital to foul ground and makes the
catch
right in front of the screening
wind took that ball but hosmer gets over
to make the grab one out base is empty
top of the order now tommy pham and his
second at bat
there's a base hit into right field able
to push it through
well placed on the right side seamer
great movement down by the label
fighting it off take it the other way
manny machado
fam takes off pitch is a strike and he
is safe
i'll chalk up another one the padres
first in thievery number 65 for san
diego this year thanks to tommy pham
machado lines it into left field becomes
tommy pham around from second
machado will pull it up around first
he's got an rbi single and the padres
have a one-nothing lead
spoiling that
slider away
two seamer that stays up and middle in
and manny says thank you very much
tommy pham
passes go collects 200
and the padres are on the board
302
and that one is caught into bounce by
wisdom throwback to first pick and a
really nice play well he continues to
play good defense patrick wisdom the
lone defender
on the left side
and wisely chose to go to first and got
the out fourth inning will commence jack
peterson's now the 1-1 to peterson
that ball is drilled peterson puts a
charge into that one way back forget it
gone
home run jack peterson unloads
on you darvish and just like that or
even
1-1 for peterson his seventh of the year
as he takes darvish deep he got in the
first nine cubs hitters
and then
whammy
we talked about it make make him stay in
the zone
he gets a breaking ball that just stays
in the middle of the zone and absolutely
hammers this
right center field
patrick wisdom
with one out and nobody on one and two
to wisdom the pitch is swung on and
missed strike three it was in the dirt
carritini will throw it down to first
base on the foul side of the bag that
completes the put out and now six
strikeouts
for u-dart afternoon padres and cubs are
tied at one
rafael ortega
into the shift here comes manny from
short right gonna hurry and he throws it
away
watch manny how he positions himself to
get in a good throwing position while
fielding he positions his left shoulder
and glove go right to the hand and then
throw and carratini backing up like a
good catcher
swing and a miss and hayward strikes out
seven strikeouts today for you darvish
really big strikeout really good pitch
from darvish one out one on and brings
up sergio alcantara
there goes a runner and a swing and a
miss throw down
not going to be in time a stolen base
fernando wants earmuffs yeah he thought
he got him on the foot maybe on the way
by
oh
yeah he got him they're going to
challenge oh yeah padres are challenging
and this appears to be an out
cubs and padres tied at one there's fab
down the 2-2
call strike three fam got four took one
right down the middle of the plate two
down and manny machado making his way to
the plate man at first
arietta the one two and a swing and a
miss nice pitch right there for jake
nick here hitting for arietta with
higgins on first base nobody out in a
tie game
fouled off to the right out of play
cascading down from the upper deck and
the
right-handed grab
baby in tow
swinging to miss and mariznick strikes
out it's eight strikeouts for darvish
one down one out runner on first base
tied at one in the six that
[Music]
reaches out grounds one to short tits
the second for one home to first for two
double play nicely done to wrap up the
top of the sixth inning arietta
outstanding and he gives way
to the new pitcher the lefty reliever
rex brothers one out in the sixth inning
for fernando 3-2
outside corner ring them up how about
that rex brothers
tatis doesn't like it he sticks around
an extra second
the bases are empty and now it's hosmer
all for two two outs three two
swing and a miss he struck him out the
cubs have him at the corners with nobody
out in the seventh inning anthony rizzo
steps to the ditch
darvish deals
[Applause]
hit on the ground softly they get one
there on to first and they get two but
hat
comes in to score and it is 2-1 rizzo
just got to put in play infields playing
back playing double play depth
nothing they can do top of the 8th
inning cubs leading the padres 2-1 the
1-1
and that one is drilled out towards
right field that one back and gone how
about that
sergio alcantra with the home run
and they get some insurance right there
as alcantara goes deep for the first
time this year and here is craig
kimbrell 14 in a row retired by cubs
pitching padres down to their last out
the 1-1
drills that one out towards right
hayward is there half calls him off
makes the grab and that is the ball game
cubs win it and take two of three
in san diego